alors comment béziers se prépare à ce
premier match du quinze de france
quelle est l'ambiance dans cette ville
qui est l'un des berceaux du rugby et
dont le club aura dominé le ballon ovale
pendant une quinzaine d'années voyez ce
reportage de jean sébastien fernandez et
de jaujac but stade de la méditerranée à
béziers la france et organise ce soir
son premier match de coupe du monde
namibie flici c'est ici aussi que le
quinze de france jouera demain à 14
heures contre le canada c'est le match
que tout le monde attend au club michel
palmié règle les derniers détails
pamiers est une figure du club six fois
champion de france avec béziers il a en
charge le dossier coupe du monde depuis
un an et demi et à l'époque personne
n'en voulait trouver ce match de coupe
du monde parce que les gens passent et
que on remplirait palestine bon moi j'ai
profité de l'opportunité pour le mamère
bon et puis la fédération française de
rugby à nous octroyer ce match à béziers
puis aujourd'hui vu l'engouement que ça
suscite
c'est quand même une bonne chose est
aussi un sacré coup de pouce pour un
club qui a marqué le rugby des années 70
et 80
limoux clie de brennus entre 71 et 84
une génération de joueurs exceptionnels
voilà pour le passé glorieux de l'as
béziers cette année le club a été
relégué en élite 2 et la coupe du monde
ici c'est l'occasion de renouer avec les
sensations du haut niveau c'est un choix
du coeur oui c'est vrai que peut-être le
public pas celui de béziers mais le
public en france auraient préféré voir
l'équipe de france démarre aide dans un
stade qui mènera à ses lèvres noblesse
le stade de france pour maintenant on
peut pas tout faire non plus au stop de
prince en ville aussi le rugby sa fiche
les supporters sont là il y a comme un
air de déjà vu mais le ballon rond a
laissé la place à l'ovale ici dès le
plus jeune âge le rugby est une religion
une religion qui a forcément c'est dieu